antenne de 20h le journal de la
rédaction
henri sannier bonsoir climat tendu et
regain de passion à la veille du
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle jacques chirac mobilisent
à paris et en auvergne à clermont
ferrand
françois mitterrand et à toulouse en ce
moment même analyse et commentaires dans
quelques instants avec l'ensemble de nos
envoyés spéciaux
protestations de la nouvelle zélande à
l'annoncé du retour appareils du
capitaine dominique prieur l'ex hausse
et pousse curan j'étais fasciné à
résidence en polynésie
à la suite de la sphère du rainbow
warrior 21 morts nouveau bilan de
l'assaut de la grotte d'ouvéa
le fln qui s appelle à une journée de
protestation demain les portes de
l'ordre mise en état d' alerte maximum
l'épreuve de force en pologne lech
walesa retranchés dans les chantiers
navals de gdansk encerclé poursuite de
la grève
à nova uta malgré l'intervention hier de
la police
didier auriol remporte le tour de corse
victoire sans discussion apport de sa
force ira devant les lancia de loubet et
s'habille le retour des trois otages
français du liban et la fin sanglante de
la sphère des otages en nouvelle
calédonie ont fait une irruption
spectaculaire c'est moins qu'on puisse
dire sur la scène électorale à trois
jours seulement du scrutin
nul doute qu'il en sera encore beaucoup
question ce soir dans les différents
meetings les images fortes de la
mobilisation à quatre heures de la
clôture officielle de la campagne nous
arrive de paris et toulouse à paris les
partisans de jacques chirac s'étaient
donné rendez vous place de la concorde
en fin d'après midi plus de quarante
mille personnes selon la fp à 19h30
avaient répondu à l'appel de
l'académicien jean d'ormesson et de
l'amiral philippe de gaulle jacques
chirac et à ses référents où il tient un
meeting en ce moment en compagnie de
valéry giscard d'estaing françois
mitterrand est attendu quant à lui à
toulouse pour son dernier grand meeting
de campagne
toulouse où le président-candidat
arrivera dans quelques minutes il aura à
ses côtés la plupart des dirigeants
socialistes
de nombreuses personnalités ont
également fait le déplacement
nous reviendrons évidemment longuement
sur ces deux événements dans quelques
minutes le temps sur nos envoyés
spéciaux de faire parvenir images et
commentaires
à deux jours du scrutin la tension est
encore accrue en nouvelle calédonie où
8000 militaires et membres des forces de
l'ordre ont été placées en état d'
alerte maximum ces dispositions
interviennent alors que le bilan de
l'intervention des forces armées pour
libérer les otages s'alourdit le dernier
bilan fait état de 21 morts 19
indépendantistes kanaks et deux
militaires 21 morts auxquels il convient
d'ajouter les quatre gendarmes tués lors
de la prise d'otages il ya une dizaine
de jours les reporters d'antenne de
françois cornet dominique merlin ont pu
se rendre dans la grotte où étaient
enfermés les otages c'est là que huit
heures durant s'est déroulé l'assaut
meurtrier
c'est sous cette jungle épaisse près de
la tribu de gossanah honor d'ouvéa que
se trouvait la grotte du fln ks la
taupinière de corail comme la surnommait
bernard pons et il est vrai que
lorsqu'on la voit de près comme j'ai pu
le faire aujourd'hui la cacher le
bastion des preneurs d'otages étaient
non seulement extrêmement difficiles à
localiser
mais encore plus à prendre tout autour
de cette grotte
les ravisseurs avaient installé des
postes de combat avec une mitrailleuse
et des fusils d'assault famas dérobé à
l'armurerie de la gendarmerie d'ouvéa
lors de la prise d'otages
tenu par de petits groupes de quatre à
cinq hommes ses positions très abrités
de la vue et des tirs d'éventuels
assaillants étaient les premiers verrou
à faire sauter pour neutraliser la
cuvette protégeant l'entrée de la grotte
pour entrer ou sortir il fallait
franchir une petite paroisse de
plusieurs mètres d'où la difficulté de
pénétrer par surprise l'opération victor
terminé on est entré maintenant dans la
phase judiciaire de cette prise d'otages
audition insolite de gendarmes par
d'autres gendarmes de la brigade de
recherche cela ce matin sur la terrasse
d'un grand hôtel de nouméa
oui ce matin le premier ministre
australien monsieur gbagbo qui a demandé
au gouvernement français de faire preuve
de compréhension pour la nouvelle
calédonie nous espérons a dit bob ho que
le fln ks n'utilisera plus la violence
et que le gouvernement français va
réactiver le dialogue fin de citation
sur place où la tension est toujours
très forte
les indépendantistes organiseront demain
une journée de protestation dominique
tierces aimé mayol pour les images les
ont rencontrés
vous allez voir que les indépendantistes
sont sur leurs gardes actuellement ici
le silence est de rigueur sur chaque
colline des postes d'observation huit
heures de présence par groupes de trois
ou quatre il y en a sur toutes les
crêpes au moindre mouvement de camions
militaires ou d'hélicoptères on prévient
les tribus les femmes les vieillards les
enfants sont évacués nac et tiges et
lima les tribus réputée dure depuis le
24 avril
accrochage incessants avec les forces de
l'ordre hier l'annoncé mort de leur
camarade
les albres ans les gens me huent verdict
au delà les candidats hier soir on ne
l'a pas caché c'était l'abattement
autour de la table mais aujourd'hui les
kanaks veut le saurez saisir dès que la
radio l'a ramassé le toner ea la grande
et la pluie il y avait des pluies
torrentielles toutes les rigueurs
indignation coup c'est tous les temps
qui étaient à côté du feu ça nous a tout
de suite rappelé la mort d'el oued de
marcel et la nature et le méchoui parce
que le genre de gars et marcel sa mort
était le même temps que le même temps
qui faisait alors qu'on nous devons
considérer que l'excellence il a passé
du moment que le tonnerre gronde les
vues et ce avec vous dans ce monde
mélanésiens les morts sont déjà acceptés
et la référence est bien sûr celle des
lois macherot le chef militaire kanak
tué en 1985 par les forces de l'ordre
son nom n'a jamais disparu de leur
discours il en est aujourd'hui que plus
présent bientôt les hommes d'ouvéa
seront mises en terre mais d'autres nous
dit-on sont déjà là prêts à prendre la
relève
nouvel accès de fièvre entre la france
et la nouvelle zélande depuis la sphère
du rainbow warrior les néo zélandais
nourrissent vous savez quelques
suspicions à notre égard
aujourd'hui le retour en france de
dominique prieur l'un des agents secrets
impliquez vous le savez dans l'attentât
contre le rainbow warrior ravive les
passions explications d'hervé brusini du
passé l'atoll d'hao la résidence
surveillée n'aura pas duré plus de deux
ans contrairement aux trois prévues par
l'accord entre la france et la
nouvelle-zélande
le capitaine prieur vivait là-bas avec
son mari devenu commandant de l'unité du
génie ce retour se fait sur la base d'un
dossier précis dit du ministère de la
défense
on sait que la jeune femme est enceinte
et son père gravement malade
mais le premier ministre néo zélandais
david languit qui a annoncé la nouvelle
fut mines
c'est une rupture des obligations
françaises at il dit ce départ n'a pas
reçu notre consentement
allusion faite au point b du compromis
passé entre les deux pays en juillet 86
il leur sera interdit de quitter l'île
et il dit pour quelques motifs que ce
soit sauf accord entre les deux
gouvernements
déjà le retour du commandant mafart
officiellement pour cause de maladie
avait provoqué la colère des autorités
de wellington
à présent les néo-zélandais ont promis
je cite on reparlera de tout cela
immédiatement après l'élection
présidentielle de dimanche
oui ce matin jacques chirac a déclaré
que le retour de dominique prieur était
conforme aux accords signés avec la
nouvelle zélande en juillet 1986 voilà
tout ce que l'on peut dire ce soir au
lendemain de la libération des otages
français au liban on commence à mieux
cerner le mécanisme de la libération on
apprend également que paris et téhéran
devrait échanger des ambassadeurs il
faut parler au conditionnel
d'ici une quarantaine de jours nous
ferons le point avec pierre serra dans
quelques instants avant cela ce soir
priorité à l'actualité les les trois ex
otages sont toujours en observation à
l'hôpital du val de grâce
on chuchotait tout à l'heure que l'un
d'entre eux devrait sortir mais nous ne
sommes pas fixé alors on fait tout de
suite le point avec dominique verdeilhan
marcel carton et marcel fontaine aurait
quitté en fin d'après-midi le quatrième
étage de l'ailé gauche de l'hôpital du
val-de-grâce hôpital dans lequel les
journalistes ne peuvent pas rentrer et
puisqu'il s'agit d'un hôpital militaire
quatrième étage service de médecine
générale du docteur dali marcel carton
aurait dit-on en juin genève où réside
sa fille simone el khoury il faut
rappeler en tout cas que c'est la
première fois que des otages de retour
du liban subissent des examens médicaux
aussi poussé on sait par leur entourage
qu'ils sont en bonne santé qu'ils ont
passé une bonne première nuit de sommeil
et qu'ils ont repris des forces mais des
tests psychologiques seront encore
nécessaires pour évaluer leurs facultés
joëlle kauffmann nous rappelait ce matin
que son époux avait des difficultés à
s'accoutumer au bruit et à la foule pour
répondre aux souhaits des familles aucun
bulletin de santé officiel n'a été
diffusée depuis hier par l'hôpital du
val de grâce et pierre serra revenons
quelques instants sur la négociation qui
a débouché sur la libération des otages
les éléments de réflexion il faut le
dire s'accumulent depuis depuis quelques
temps j'ai sous les yeux une des pages
de la fp1 qui qui donne un calendrier
précis relatifs aux engagements
réciproques qui aurait été pris à la
fois par paris et par par téhéran que
faut-il en penser vert écouter cette
dépêche fait état de
renseignements ou d'information prise au
sua des sources proches des négociateurs
c'est pas officiel donc se sont dit pas
des racontars ma faim n ya plus de
distorsions quand même la seule
information officielle on dispose c'est
la déclaration de jacques chirac à
villacoublay hier n'a qu un réseautage
d'ingrédients gros nous pouvons
maintenant envisager valablement dans le
cadre des relations entre états la
normalisation de nos relations avec
terre ça c'est important
alors cette dépêche faut le comprendre
en revanche donne beaucoup de détails
elle dit par exemple que un calendrier
de quatre journées le dire en trois
étapes pourraient parvenir pourrait
permettre de parvenir à la rouverture et
ambassades réciproque à paris à téhéran
procès c'est une chose et puis a dit
surtout que pour apurer le contentieux
financier entre paris et téhéran cantos
économique donc on est arrivé aussi un
calendrier que les iraniens exigerait
deux choses d'abord de d'entrée
carrément dans le capital d'être
actionnaire à part entière de redire
c'est une chose mais surtout que le
gouvernement français se serait engagé à
fournir à l'iran de l'uranium enrichi
et ça c'est impensable parce que ça
pourrait signifier une première lecture
que finalement on va donner à l'iran les
moyens de construire une bombe atomique
c'est impensable mais alors là vous
aviez messi avait anguille sous roche on
sait jamais après tout il n'ya pas eu de
démenti après tous deux y ait démenti
qu'ils ont fait sur des spéculations que
bon c'est probablement ça c'est une
autre que rennes peut électorale mais
imaginons qui en guise sous roche
alors je crois qu'il faut rappeler
certaines choses rappelez-vous en 1980
les israéliens pour les mêmes raisons de
danger avait détruit une centrale
nucléaire en irak à tamouz qui
et a été conçu par les français qui ont
surtout proposé aux irakiens puisque on
maintient notre haute garonne aux
engagements de reconstruire cette
centrale est de fournir là aussi de
l'uranium enrichi mais pas n'importe
quelle hargne sommes enrichis lui a même
qu'on appelle caramel qui est enrichi
mais pas suffisamment pour fabriquer
bombe atomique alors je vais vous dire
ça fait sept ans que la négociation avec
l'irak dur on a parcouru la première
pierre de cette cuisine et on attend
toujours alors les iraniens en
l'occurrence de vente toujours avec tous
le même traitement qu avec l'irak
puisque on a une politique avec l'irak
qui voudraient connaît même avec eux
alors sur mena pour sept ans avec eux en
attendant parvenir
le principal c'est que les otages sont
sortis merci pierre en pologne
retournement de situation il a 48 heures
l'ambiance vous le savez nous vous le
disions sur cette antenne était à
l'apaisement mais hier les forces de
l'ordre sont intervenues à nova où tu as
les membres du comité de grève ont
d'ailleurs été arrêtés situation
extrêmement tendue également à gdansk où
les chantiers lénine sont encerclés par
la police
les grévistes s'attendent à une
offensive des forces de sécurité lech
walesa qui est toujours retranché dans
l'enceinte des chantiers navals a fait
savoir qu'ils lutteraient jusqu'au bout
martine laroche-joubert une citadelle
assiégée
c'est l'image aujourd'hui des chantiers
lénine de gdansk l'extérieur quadrillée
par les homos les unités anti-émeutes en
tenue de combat matraque au ceinturon en
attente d'un ordre d'intervention faut
trancher à l'intérieur les grévistes
avec lech walesa les plus jeunes ceux
qui n'ont pas connu les grèves de 1980
sont les plus déterminés ils veulent que
aussi le pouvoir de décider mais ils
applaudissent toujours les cheveux les
arts lorsqu'il se déclare prêt à aller
jusqu'au bout et a quitté le dernier les
chantiers l'humour même détermination
aux aciéries de nova autant malgré
l'intervention hier des forces de
l'ordre à l'intérieur même de lusine 40
blessés des dizaines d'arrestations
la grève continue et s'organisent au
mépris des risques les familles
apportent des vivres au nouveau comité
de grève la plupart des anciens membres
ont été arrêtés
nova ou ta danse des noms qui éclate
aujourd'hui comme un défi
les télégrammes d'actualité avec
isabelle tess ensuite nous ouvrirons le
dernier journal de la campagne des
présidentielles
le président afghan refuse d'accorder
une mesure de grâce à alain guilhot
ainsi qu'un journaliste italien détenus
à kaboul les deux hommes ont participé
au conflit et pénétré illégalement en
afghanistan affirme najib ou là il
répond ainsi à une pétition de 52
journalistes réclamant la libération de
leurs confrères
les écologistes de greenpeace à bord
d'une frégate soviétique pour lui coller
le symbole de radioactivité une action
qui a failli leur coûter la vie un canot
pneumatique l'ayant chaviré près du
navire
selon greenpeace le bâtiment soviétique
transportent des ogives nucléaires
gigantesque carambolage ce matin dans la
région de dunkerque 40 véhicules dont un
camion citerne chargé d'un produit
toxique se sont percutés sur la
nationale 2 125 15 personnes ont été
légèrement blessées
le brouillard est à l'origine de
l'accident les partisans de jacques
chirac mobilise c'était tout à leur
place de la concorde à paris à l'appel
de l'académicien jean d'ormesson et de
l'amiral philippe de gaulle
plus de quarante mille personnes selon
la fp daté de 19h30
quarante mille personnes se sont donc
rassemblés un mot d'ordre la sauvegarde
de la république reportage olivier
werner roland sicard
mes chers amis dimanche la france aura à
choisir entre le déclin elle
redressement dimanche comme non annoncé
raymond tard et georges chirac la france
devra choisir son avenir fort elle même
et pour nos enfants qui mangent
il conviendra de gagner avec jacques
chirac
pendant ce temps là jacques chirac est à
clermont ferrand aux côtés de valérie
giscard d'estaing nous appellerons
clairement dans quelques minutes
françois mitterrand lui est à toulouse
où il tient tant ce moment le tout
dernier meeting de sa campagne lui aussi
le candidat mitterrand est entouré de
tous les ténors du parti socialiste et
d'un certain nombre de personnalités
l'ambiance avant le discours du candidat
mitterrand avec nos envoyés spéciaux
rachid arhab jean-michel mercurol
toulouse ultime grand-messe de la
campagne mitterrand avant le verdict
après demain meeting géant sva triple
chapiteau et une présentant la tribune
du président-candidat installé
symboliquement au centre rituel immuable
politiques vedettes du show-biz au
premier rang une affiche grand spectacle
comme à chacun des meetings
vous avez choisi françois mitterrand
j'aime bien au programme ce soir charles
trenet jacques higelin et barbara c'est
sur sa chanson qu avait été donné le
coup d'envoi de la campagne c'est elle
qui la termine
auparavant pierre joxe avait parlé lui
d'une autre manifestation moins poétique
il ya plus de trente ans que je vois
tour
la première fois que je vois une
manifestation de masse organisées entre
l'assemblée nationale et l'elysée à la
veille d'un spécial je trouve que ce
n'est pas de très bon aloi halfon bhl
pour françois mitterrand ici à toulouse
beaucoup de gens sont encore dehors au
moment où il parle
les socialistes ont fait en sorte qu'il
n'est pas à envier les foules réunies
par leurs concurrents beaucoup de monde
également place de la concorde 40
peut-être même 50 mille personnes cent
mille selon les organisateurs je pense
que nous retournerons place de la
concorde tout à l'heure maintenant
direction l'auvergne avec une autre
image qui symbolise l'unité au sein de
la majorité jacques chirac valéry
giscard d'estaing participe en ce moment
à clermont ferrand à un nouveau meeting
jacques chirac a évoqué la façon d'agir
de son gouvernement tente au niveau de
la nouvelle calédonie que à la façon de
le libérer les otages français au liban
reportage en lui le scène laurent
bouvier nous avons ramené nos otages du
liban
nous l'avons fait dans des conditions
chacun doit le savoir qu'ils sont
conformes
cela va de soi l'honneur et la dignité
de notre pays c'est à dire sans l'ombre
d'une compromission
sans l'ombre d'une tractation avec
quelques groupes terroristes que ce soit
sans aucune contrepartie clonée aux
autorités gouvernementales grâce auquel
nous avons pu obtenir satisfaction
c'est simplement en faisant valoir à
quel point il était peu conforme à
l'honneur d'une nation de se rendre
complice d'actes de barbarie que nous
avons eu satisfaction
c'est dans cet esprit et je suis heureux
de le dire en face d'andré giraud notre
ministre de la dépense
que nous avons agi en nouvelle calédonie
lorsqu'il est apparu clairement que le
dialogue ou la négociation ne
conduisaient à rien si ce n'est à métro
notamment mettre en danger nos otages
et c'est la raison pourquoi j'ai pris la
responsabilité d'une action militaire
qui a été réussi et je voudrais rendre
hommage à notre armée est un autre
gendarmerie qui agit avec compétence
avec intelligence et avec dévouement
retour à toulouse où françois mitterrand
vient tout juste de prendre la parole je
vous propose d'écouter le candidat
mitterrand c'était il ya quelques
instants seulement
direction toulouse je ne veux pas me
mêler des accusations personnelles je ne
mets pas les personnes sans cause
j'observe même c'est cette façon de
faire avec un peu de tristesse j'espère
que les jours qui vont suivre
nettoieront l'atmosphère est ce que vous
pourriez vous nous mettre à sa place
et qu'est ce que vous auriez fait au
moment de la libération des trois otages
de beyrouth est ce que nous ferons vous
n'auriez pas eu la même attitude que lui
la libération des trois otages du liban
comment ne m'en serais pas réjoui hier
je les dis tout aussitôt qu'elle
français qui n'a pas éprouvé pour
lui-même les autres avec joie un
sentiment de délivrance donc dans mon
cas ça me serait encore plus difficile
de ne pas partager ce sentiment là que
j'ai contribué à parvenir à ce résultat
donc non il n'y a pas de distinction à
faire entre le gouvernement et moi dans
une matière aussi sensible
quand on se représente pour un second
septennat c'est qu'on a envie de laisser
sa trace dans l'histoire
ce que vous aimeriez qu'on dit de vaud
bidart coutaller sont les historiens
agir demain
ce que j'espère en tout cas ses pouvoirs
dans ce deuxième septennat engagé le
chantier dont j'ai parlé par l'éducation
nationale et par la recherche
scientifique la formation de notre
jeunesse et l'accession de cette
jeunesse de grandes responsabilités et
d'autre part que nous nous attaquions
tous ensemble aux graves anxiété au
grade malaise de la vie quotidienne qui
sollicitent les français un chat coeur
de leur journée oui je pense que vous
l'avez compris ça ne trompe personne
françois mitterrand n'est pas encore
arrivé à toulouse le meeting a commencé
avec ses supporters et notamment de
nombreuses stars du show-business et
aussi des stars du sport
nous y reviendrons dans les derniers
jours notamment dans le dernier journal
ce soir vers 22h50 ça c'était une
interview qui était accordée à nos
confrères de tf1 tout à l'heure
l'interview qui est assurons soyons en
sûr la dernière interview de la campagne
alors que lamar on a l'impression que la
campagne s'achève dans un climat
beaucoup plus passionnelle je crois que
le terme n'est pas trop fort oui ce sont
les dernières images que l'on vienne
voir en vrac de cette campagne
électorale qu'on reverra ce soir vous
l'avais dit à 22h45 demain repos repos
des guerriers et silence et suspense
jusqu'à dimanche ce jour là ce sont les
électeurs qui décideront des lectures
qui ont suivi comme nous une campagne
très particulière elle a basculé en fait
le 28 avril dernier jeudi dernier lors
du face à face entre les deux candidats
avant ce débat le combat politique et
est moins aigu que lors des précédentes
élections présidentielles nous étions
d'ailleurs tous persuadés que la
cohabitation avec ont contribué à
atténuer l'aspect souvent brutales de
ces élections présidentielles mais c'est
vrai que depuis ce débat télévisé le ton
a changé plus rude plus dur
la bataille eut à fleurets mouchetés a
fait place à une bataille frontale entre
les deux candidats françois mitterrand
jacques chirac qui ne se sont fait aucun
cadeau cette passion que l'on a vu ces
derniers jours
va-t-elle leur tombait après le 8 mai on
pourrait dans un premier réflexe le
penser la co existence institutionnelle
avait permis croyez ton
kr est définitivement un climat de paix
civile me ce n'est plus sûr aujourd'hui
il est possible qu'on retrouve au
contraire quel que soit l'élu
quel que soit l'élu le schéma d'avant la
cohabitation il est possible qu'on
retrouve face à face dans une opposition
sans concession après le 8 mai deux
camps j'allais dire de france de caen
dominé l'un par le parti socialiste
l'autre par le rpr le paradoxe veut que
ce soit ces deux camps qui est cohabiter
pendant deux ans dans ces conditions que
deviendront les deux autres partis qui
ont marqué
sinon dominé la vie politique sur le
cinquième le parti communiste et l'udf
résisteront ils à l'appétit des deux
grands ou survivront titre c'est la
question qu'il se pose dès aujourd'hui
sans même attendre le résultat de
l'élection présidentielle
mais il ya une autre question qui hante
tous les esprits et que toute la classe
politique que se pose quel rôle jouera
celui que l'on a appelé le grand
perturbateur
autrement dit jean marie le pen
réussira-t-il à imposer sa loi à imposer
ses thèmes ses discours dans le débat
politique
réussira-t-il à imprimer sa marque c'est
à dire à durcir un climat politique déjà
tendue
ou sera-t-il marginalisés la réponse à
cette interrogation sera déterminante
pour l'avenir du pays pour l'évolution
de la société française peut-être plus
déterminante que le résultat du deuxième
tour de l'élection présidentielle là
c'est paul on retrouve quand même
dimanche soir partir de 19h50 avec
bernard rapp sur le plateau et claude
sérillon sport essentiellement le tour
de corse hier
coup dur pour l'enfant du pays yves
loubet auriol sur bmw on avait profité
vous le savez pour prendre le
commandement
mais derrière vézien et sa vie était en
embuscade prête à exploiter la moindre
erreur aujourd'hui auriol a fait la
différence
sérieusement sur la route du tour de
corse j'appelle tout de suite notre
envoyé spécial thierry blancot premier
podium en championnat du monde des
rallyes première victoire au tour de
corse et premier succès comme pilote
d'usiné
continuons rien ça serait pas facile
avec kiel bluebay été un partenaire très
dangereux ici qu'il allait aller très
vite il fallait quand même pas oublier
bernard vega aussi qui connaissait bien
la corde comme pour nous la chasse à la
chasse a été pendant aujourd'hui et on
est très content pas content du tout par
contre yves loubet un record pourtant 22
victoires en spéciales sur 30
le b terminent seconds comme l'année
dernière une minute de retard hier à
peine 3 aujourd'hui arbitre du duel
auriol loubet sortie de route ce matin
dans la 23ème spéciale pour béguin 15
minutes perdues arrière de la bmw abîmé
résultats 7e à plus de 23 minutes
troisième place pour l'autre l'ancien
officiel de bruno saby
quarante deux équipages sur 93 ce soir
ajaccio rallye marathon de 1400 km le
tour de corse reste le plus beau mais
aussi le plus difficile
après la corse le toit du monde comme si
vous y étiez les images que vous allez
voir on était filmé en direct par une
équipe de la nhk la télévision japonaise
vertige garantie au sommet de l'everest
mais oui avec jean ma mère la preuve est
là l'everest est bien le toit du monde
pas un sommet aux alentours ne domine
mais pour mériter cette vue les cinq
alpinistes trois japonais et deux
sherpas népalais en direct fait vivre
leurs dernières souffrent ce manque
d'oxygène difficulté de trouver le bon
chemin
à plus de 8000 mètres l'homme redevient
tout petit et vulnérables bizarrement ce
sont les derniers mètres qui sont le
plus difficile certains ont bien du mal
à terminer un exploit pareil mérite bien
la photo normal pour un japonais mais
encore plus fort et nouveau surtout
c'est l'interview en direct de ces
conquérants de l'inutile depuis
longtemps l'everest n'était plus vierge
mais avec le satellite aujourd'hui
limaille alisme a franchi un nouveau pas
l'everest quant à lui a pris un air de
déjà vu
demain dans samedi passion finale avant
la lettre du championnat de france de
rugby avec le quart de finale toulouse
toulon en direct sur antenne 2 à partir
de 15h précisément retour à la politique
je vous le disais tout à l'heure nous
recevons à l'instant même les toutes
dernières images de la manifestation des
partisans du candidat chirac place de la
concorde à paris
tout de suite le reportage d'olivier
lerner et roland sicard
côté jardin des tuileries entrée des
artistes et des officiels et il y avait
du beau monde
la majorité mobilise aussi dans le
show-business dernier jour de la
campagne officielle au rpr comme à l'udf
on a épluché minutieusement les carnets
d adresses et on a même découvert des
militants qu'on ne soupçonnait pas je
crois j'ai toujours été bien entendu
foncièrement la loi je pense que la
france est beaucoup plus attachés et que
la gauche sensiblement plus d'électeurs
qui votent qui sont présents et sans
laisse mobilisent plus facilement que la
droite et je crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est
la pause que la droite aussi peut se
mobiliser une droite qui se retrouvent
sans toit incliné 81 saison pour la
rigueur l'amiral de gauche pour la
tradition tous les gaullistes sont là
des gaullistes qui croient dames et
messieurs
il nous reste trente six heures pour
convaincre les indécis
c'est vrai que l'espoir a changé de camp
c'est vrai que maintenant tout est
possible nous allons gagner dimanche
chirac sur le président pasqua prost
tout bon léotard gaudin pour chauffer la
foule
mais ici on voudrait surtout voir et
entendre le candidat premier ministre
la rumeur est tenace et jacques chirac
passer son meeting de clermont pourrait
faire un crochet par la place de la
concorde
les pronostics de pierrette brès pour le
tiercé de demain c'est sur l'hippodrome
de vincennes
il y a vingt partants c'est beaucoup une
épreuve de trot attelé que ce grand prix
du vivarais les pronostics vous le lisez
comme moi le 15 le vin le 19 le 17 le 12
le 3 le 7 et le 4 je récapitule vite
fait le 15
le vin le 19 le 17 le 12 le 3 le 7 et le
4 mai dernier journal ce soir vers 22h45
avec aubry et de l'air pendant le
week-end vous retrouverez comme
d'habitude daniel bilalian philippe
gayssot et bernard rapp pour l'assiette
anglaise
dimanche c'est important noté le lien à
partir de 19h55 n'oubliez pas la grande
soirée de résultats consacrée à
l'élection présidentielle grâce à
antenne 2 comme d'habitude
vous serez une nouvelle fois les
premiers sur l'événement je retrouve
lundi fidèle au poste
bonsoir
oh